[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning we are
learning about a surprising move by one
of the grand jurors who looked into the
brianna taylor case that juror
is calling for information from the
secret proceedings to be made public
meantime the kentucky attorney general
confirms he did not recommend murder
charges to the grand jury
taylor of course was killed in march
during a botched police raid
and the grand jury decided last week not
to charge the louisville police officers
with any crimes in connection
with taylor's death adriana diaz is in
louisville for us adriana
good morning to you good morning this is
so unusual that an attorney familiar
with the case
told me he has never seen anything like
this in the notice the grand juror says
they only want the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
but the reason the attorney general is
releasing these proceedings is because
he was ordered to do so
by a judge it happened yesterday at the
arraignment performer detective brett
hankinson
news was breaking by almost the hour
yesterday and late last night
the attorney general's office told us
that they do plan to release
those secret proceedings the grand
jury voted to return an indictment
against detective hankinson last week
kentucky attorney general daniel cameron
announced that the grand jury in the
brianna taylor case
would only charge former detective brett
hankinson with wanton endangerment
for firing his weapon into taylor's
neighbor's apartment
yesterday hankerson was arraigned
pleading not guilty
then in a stunning twist a member of
that grand jury filed a notice
requesting the proceedings be made
public
according to the notice the juror
accused cameron of using the grand
jurors as a shield
to deflect accountability and
responsibility for these decisions
detective cosgrove and sergeant
mattingly
were justified in returning fire because
they were fired upon
late last night cameron confirmed he
only recommended the charge of wanton
endangerment against detective henkerson
to the grand jury
because he said the evidence supports
that the other officers were justified
in the shooting
out of self-defense you believe this is
a cover-up
absolutely it was a cover-up frederick
moore the attorney for kenny walker
taylor's boyfriend believes the evidence
will show the officers violated the law
when they shot at taylor and walker
walker admits to firing a warning shot
first officials say that shot hit an
officer
walker's attorneys say it may not have i
believe when all of the facts are
revealed people will see that these
officers were not justified in their
actions
these developments come the same day
vice news published audio reportedly
from an interview louisville police
investigators conducted with swat
commander lieutenant dale massey
who responded to the scene after the
shooting it was just
an egregious act i mean
from our perspective if that's in fact
what happened if other details come to
light
it is what it is the audio has not been
independently verified by cbs news
but david james the president of the
louisville metro council says these
developments degrade the integrity of
the case
i don't know how the grand jury could
have came up with his conclusions
a former prosecutor and criminal defense
attorney tells us that releasing these
secret grand jury proceedings
sets a terrible precedent the attorney
general's office deadline to do so
is noon tomorrow boy adriana thank you
it seems the more information you hear
about the case the more questions you
have about this case
certainly more to come thank you very
much adriana diaz